[Music]
all right let's go to matt in hartford
what's up brother meth you
how are you doing today good my man
what's up
thank you for taking my call first of
all so i've got a bit of a difficult
financial situation i'm very fortunate
to be in this position but i've still
kind of i've got a lot of expenses
piling up and i'm kind of just worried
about how that's what the best way is to
navigate it
so
i was able to purchase a house in cash
it's been a dream of mine for many years
and i saved up for many years and i was
also in a very fortunate position to be
gifted with some of money from my family
as well and all that together meant that
i was able to buy a house in cash but
the problem that i'm running into now is
that i have a very large amount of
repairs that needs to get done up with
the property and i have a very limited
amount of cash left after spending all
of it on buying the house and i'm just
wondering about the best way to
potentially cash flows in these repairs
and if my income is going to be enough
to do that and if i might need to get a
second job potentially
to in order to help pay for some of it
okay so what's your income
so i just got a new job and it'll be 44
000 a year and how much money do you
have in the bank
liquid right now i have about 11 11 000
in cash i just wrote a check for 6 800
bucks so when that clears i i have
11 grand left in cash okay and is that
your emergency fund at that point or
part of it yes so we gotta build that
emergency fund
okay so what i want you to do is
separate out your emergency fund from
the home repair fund because i'm worried
that they become two in one and all of a
sudden you are very very broke
yeah that's what i'm worried about too
how what's the urgency of these repairs
can you do them over the next six months
i mean is it a safe place to live
i'm hoping that i can i think i can but
i don't 100 know like there's some
things that i need urgently addressing
like i just wrote a check for 6800 bucks
for asbestos removal that was urgent i
had to get that done
and i've got electrical problems and
i've got an electrician coming next week
to uh hopefully sort out that but i'm
guessing it's going to be i don't know
exactly how much it's going to cost
people i've estimated a few thousand
because the amount of electric work that
needs to get done is expensive half the
likes of my place don't work was this a
fixer-upper yeah why'd you buy this
house man did you get an inspection
appraisal on it
i know i didn't get it i
my realtor advised me to waive the
inspection because of the market that
we're in with the real estate market
being what it is i was fortunate i
didn't have to pay over asking price
like you're exactly asking oh you're
paying for it you're not fortunate
brother you're paying your real estate
agent encouraged you because they got
the fee
man
how much did you pay for this house
200 000
well the good news is you don't have a
mortgage and so you have more margin in
your income i would get the side job in
order at least until the repairs are
done and it's in good living condition
have you
matt have you sat down and written out
all of the repairs you're going to need
i have
i have a pretty extensive list
there are some things that i don't know
for sure exactly when they need to get
done for instance i know i need a roof
done but i was told that i might have up
to a year before i really need to need
to get it done like i was told it wasn't
it's not something i need to get in
tomorrow right now if i'm you here's
what i would do this is me just telling
you exactly what i would do if i'm in
your shoes
i would pay the money and i would um go
get an inspect a home inspection and
have somebody a professional walk
through it from from nose to tail it'll
cost you a few hundred bucks yes and
it's gonna be
money well well spent
and they're gonna give you a list a 20
or 30 page document with photos and say
here's everything that would make the
house just able to be sold
and then you can ask the inspector they
walk through it with you as part of this
and say what has to be done right now
and that way it's that will give you
some peace because you don't even know
how big of an elephant you're trying to
eat right now
you're just scarfing down every little
bit that you can and what you're gonna
do is like george said you're gonna end
up broke and you're gonna end up fixing
one thing and you should have spent the
money over here so dude you need a plan
back up slow down you i
me i'm real tempted to tell them george
to sell the house because dude this
could be a force we don't know how much
of a money
and then the inspector goes dude this
you're looking at a hundred grand to get
i mean who knows if you need a new roof
the foundation's messed up the asbestos
i mean it keeps adding up right this
thing's a loss so i would get that thing
i would get an inspection done they're
going to give you a big report and you
walk through with them the inspectors
that i've worked at in the past are
they're just great and they work for you
so they're going to tell you the truth
um and i'd get that done asap man um and
then yeah you're going to have you're
gonna know what kind of hole you've dug
and then that's gonna dictate what kind
of side job you need to get or two side
jobs or three side jobs but please
remember what george said do not
just dump all of your quote unquote
extra money that's not being used for
bills into the same pot you've got to
have an emergency fund that sits over
here for true emergencies when that roof
caves in on you right and you got to go
get that thing fixed yeah this house is
very quickly turning from a blessing
into a curse that's right and i'm proud
of him for saving up the money and of
course there's some family money that
came in to help him do this with cash
which is amazing
but a lot of people right now john are
making some bad decisions when it comes
to housing because of fear that's right
and because agreed they're going well
now is the time if i don't do it now
i'll never do it and my realtor said my
realtor said don't do anything you're
not comfortable with that's right and if
you're not comfortable with it get a new
realtor but do not wave inspections and
appraisals because you end up in a
situation like this even with no
mortgage he's stressed out to his
eyeballs that's right um
i mean i just personally i had helms
inspected when you're trying to buy
nashville you know it's like trying to
buy nashville and i walked away from a
few deals because i didn't know once we
put a shovel in the ground i don't know
what that step pick's gonna actually the
damage you know it's going to give 4000
to 60. well that's a big margin right
and so i walked away from a few deals
and to my realtor it was hard it was
frustrating but dude i'm not going to
buy a home i'm not going to buy that big
of an investment without somebody
telling me what i'm what i'm it's the
biggest purchase of your life this is
not the time to go yeah we'll buy it
sight unseen as is i'm sure it'll be
fine cool man yeah cause it man those
those repairs
could be a mess let me ask you this
george so um
let's
back up and say this guy could do this
over
principle-wise financially
if he instead of putting um and i don't
remember exactly what he said how much
he uh how much did he say he got in the
it was 200 grand so he paid cash okay
if he had mortgaged 125 of that i mean
i'm sorry he had mortgage 75 of that put
125 down and then kept 75 000 for
potential repairs and then once that
smoke clears to put the rest of that
money is that yeah i like that plan
cause then you're putting 75 down on
this house
and that you you leave yourself some
cash to live with right well if you're
buying a house that you don't know much
about because you didn't get an
inspection i'm going to assume there's
some problems i need to fix and
therefore i need to have the funds to
make sure i can fix that yeah anyone who
talks
reserve on top of that gonna sell you
something and they say you're not
allowed to look and see if it actually
works or not that should be a big red
flag maybe i shouldn't buy that yeah if
i'm buying a car from a stranger i'm
going i'm gonna get this thing inspected
yes that's a car not a house not a house
that's right so i treat it the same way